para algunos latinos si es tan fácil
como tener una visa y montarse en un
avión llegan a eeuu para vacunarse a
pesar del estatus de turista personas de
toda latinoamérica optan por el llamado
turismo de vacunas toman ventaja de una
de las campañas de vacunación más
exitosas y masivas del mundo mientras
sus programas nacionales avanzan a paso
lento pues la verdad me parece muy bien
que tengan la oportunidad de salir al
extranjero y que les puedan poner la
vacuna ya que si aqui en mexico no hay
la oportunidad y tardan
y allá hay allá la gente allá el
gobierno de eeuu le dice a la gente que
se va unen y la gente pues no van desde
perú aquellos que pueden permitírselo
prefiere no esperar su turno para
inmunizarse algo de lo que han sacado
provecho las agencias de viaje
los viajes de turismo y aprovecharlo del
abajo
hace un año que no viajamos
y aprovechamos
y la florida
reformamos
el 6 de mayo la ciudad de nueva york
anunció que aplicaría la monodosis de
johnson y johnson a turistas en lugares
emblemáticos de la ciudad y en otros
estados del país como florida o texas
los visitantes también pueden recibir
inmunizantes eeuu y ha administrado casi
262 millones de dosis más que duplicando
la cantidad de inoculantes en toda
américa latina
el ejecutivo de vaivén está teniendo
problemas para inmunizar a la población
antes de verano como prometió debido al
escepticismo de muchos ciudadanos
respecto a las vacunas